bonsoir et bienvenue à charny ou plutôt
charny aurait de puisaye pour être plus
précis car il ya trois ans 14 communes
de ce canton fusionner pour former cette
commune nouvelle souvenez vous c'est une
petite révolution qui est en train de
s'opérer dans ce secteur de l'uab 14
communes du canton de charny vont
fusionner et ne formeront alors plus
qu'un seul village de plus de 5000
habitants
dès le 1er janvier ici on reste
dubitatif n'étiez pas au courant qu'elle
nouvelles communes nos rejets des
conneries ça charny aurait de puiser ça
vous dit rien
pas tellement non l'élection du nouveau
maire par le conseil municipal aura lieu
le 5 janvier
en attendant ici on cherche encore un
nom aux habitants de la commune nouvelle
alors aujourd'hui charniers aurait
depuis their c5200 habitants c'est la
sixième commune de l'yonne en terme de
population
alors qu'est ce que ça a changé pour les
habitants ça tombe bien aujourd'hui
c'est jour de marché on va sûrement
rencontrer quelques-uns à monsieur linh
question que je me pose est comment ils
s'appellent les nouveaux habitants de
charniers au réduisait les chars ni quoi
et moi je suis né ici en 1954 c'était
déjà ça et ça continue et je vois pas
pourquoi ça changerait
bonjour madame bon à l'époque on parlait
d'une révolution pour charniers aurait
de puiser ça vraiment été une révolution
cette nouvelle commune pour moi non on a
plus d'entretien dans notre commune déjà
les routes sont moins entre nous on est
moins servi mais on paye autant qu est
ce que ça a changé du coup la nouvelle
commune de charny aurait de puisaye
c'est la merde c'est la merde
j'habite à 21,3 né j'ai uniquement les
adresses où le courrier que la rallonge
le courrier sud est dans le pré il faut
mettre ce dernier aurait de fusée avant
alors permettez que saint martin sur moi
non ça permet à la commune nouvelle de
pouvoir mutualiser des moyens afin
d'amener des nouveaux services à la
population des services qui n'existaient
pas puis ça permet à la population
d'avoir une vision territoriale alors
qu'habituellement on avait plus tendance
à respirer à l'ombre de son clocher quoi
voilà mes jeux pour moi c'est positif
ont visiblement à les avis sont assez
partagés sur charnières réduisait à
bastien j'aperçois le maire là bas on va
lui poser quelques questions au revoir
monsieur le maire
bonjour bon ya trois ans charny devenait
charniers aurait de puisaye on parlait
d'une petite révolution à l'époque ça a
changé beaucoup de choses vraiment ah
oui un peu quand même parce que si vous
voulez c'est toute une réorganisation
administrative réorganisation du
territoire avec des changements de noms
de rues rit ça ça a été un grand moment
où les changements
bruhin dans les hameaux et même dans les
bourgs c'est le changement de rue rue de
l'égalité par exemple j'en avais 14
ben là ça pose un vrai souci et là ça
nous a amené quelques contestations même
des fois un peu violente de la part de
nos concitoyens
non monsieur le maire par contre un
petit souci parce que les noms des rues
ont été changés mais les panneaux
d'entrée de la commune
eux ils sont toujours les mêmes c'est
exact alors pourquoi simplement
l'investissement était d'à peu près de
15000 euros
et comme c'est des routes
départementales on attend tranquillement
que le département le fasse c'est pas
pour nous le plus important
mais le gros changement à charny aurait
de puisaye c'est le nombre d'élus 14
villages donc autant de maires délégués
ajoutez à cela une soixantaine de
conseillers municipaux
faites le calcul ça fait au total 77
élus autour de la table ça fait beaucoup
tout le monde y participe
non non non il y en a une trentaine qui
viennent jamais et vous qui parlez de
faire des économies quand même c'est pas
très bien vu sa couille alors ça ne fait
pas d'économies mais ça nous coûte rien
puisque son par énumérer ce sont des
simples conseillers municipaux
heureusement que les habitants de charny
aurait de puisaye se rassure à partir de
2020 il ne restera plus que 33 élus une
économie de 150 mille euros par an
chaque ancien village aura son adjoint
référent
comme à villefranche et ses 600
habitants bonjour monsieur le maire
délégué je crois que ça tout à fait
visiblement à villefranche c'est
toujours des bureaux on peut toujours
faire l'état civil effectivement on a
toujours une mairie certes des heures
d'ouverture
réduite mais on peut toujours se marier
villefranche on a toujours notre état
civil comme avant comme avant rien n'est
changé
villefranche fait partie des 14 villages
qui se sont regroupés dans la commune
nouvelle
un regroupement qui a permis de
redynamiser le petit bourg ça donc c'est
notre nouvelle boulangerie c'est un
projet que conduit la commune nouvelle
et je sens la commune nouvelle nous
n'aurions pu conduire ce projet faute de
capacité financière cette commune elle
bénéficie du dynamisme que l'on met dans
la commune nouvelles comme la culture
par hamza sommes et de ce fait on
organise des spectacles qu'on n'avait
pas l'habitude d'organiser comme un
concert comme un cinéma en plein air
voilà c'est très positif mais il ya
aussi un aspect négatif ou pas de ce
regroupement
alors effectivement on ya un aspect
négatif c'est celui du service technique
qui n'a pas la même réactivité que en
local à l'époque mais voilà on travaille
et des actions sont là pour développer
ce service technique et le rendent aussi
efficace et croyez le ou non avec ses
230 kilomètres carrés charny aurait de
puiser est aujourd'hui aussi grande que
la ville de marseille depuis janvier
onze communes nouvelles ont été créées
dans l'yonne